il découvrait de la une vaste étendue de
pays devant lui au bas de la pente
inclinée vers le midi les temps de buzy
dans cette allée sur le bord de la route
au delà d'autres étant louise et vers
l'ouest semblable à de grands miroirs
matt raboliot les nommés en lui-même
ardilla le biais de la guette chanteloup
il fut compta bienvenu ici incendie de
l'hôtel dans le loiret dernière étape de
notre périple régional consacré aux
maisons d'écrivains la maison de maurice
genevoix c'est son petit fils julien
larrère genevois qui nous en ouvre les
portes
bonjour bienvenue aux vernets la maison
de maurice genevoix depuis 1927
[Musique]
on est ici dans la bibliothèque des
vernets le salon là où mon grand père
recevait ses amis et cette pièce elle
est importante pour lui parce que c'est
lui qui l'a dessinée comme tout le reste
de la maison lorsqu'il l'a acheté cette
maison il n'y avait pas par exemple la
rotonde qui est là et c'est lui qui l'a
voulu comme ça avec ses trois ouvertures
sur sur le jardin et je trouve que ça
dit assez bien son envie d'être en
communion avec la nature et on retrouve
cette même communion avec les fenêtres
qui donnent ici sur la loi donc c'est
véritablement une maison au bord de la
loire tout près de la loire et avec la
à
je suis devenu pêcheur je suis devenu un
fanatique de la loire gelé connu je
vivais dessus au bord de dents si bien
que l s'est incorporé en quelque sorte à
la substance et à ma sensibilité
profonde c'est tout à fait naturel et
normal
et donc au dessus de cette pièce nous
allons aller dans le bureau qui est la
pièce la plus importante de la maison
saloum origines voient passer le plus de
temps
[Musique]
e
donc cette pièce qui est celle à mon
avis qui résume peut-être le mieux qui
était maurice genevoix et c'est là où il
a son empreinte la plus forte
cette pièce n'a pas du tout été modifiée
elle est vraiment telle qu'elle était à
son époque
et donc juste à côté du bureau nous
arrivons dans une autre pièce qui est ce
que nous appelons le grenier qui a été
une pièce qui a été construite par ma
grand mère justement pour permettre à
l'écrivain de travailler tranquillement
et en réalité beaucoup plus pour
permettre à la famille de vivre aussi
pendant que l'écrivain travail est
tranquillement puisque la pièce qu'on a
vu tout au début la bibliothèque n'y a
pas de séparation et donc les bruits
monthey et empêcher mon grand-père de
travailler alors que là il ya cette
double porte donc qui permet de vivre
pendant que l'écrivain travaille d'abord
maurice genevoix c'est quelqu'un qui
peut être parce qu'il avait vécu les
souffrances de la grande guerre était
très tournée vers l'amitié est donc
cette maison ça a été une maison de vie
ça a été une maison de joie et une
maison de plaisir aussi et c'était très
important et maurice genevoix était
quelqu'un qui aimait rire qui faisaient
des blagues et il en avait une qui était
un de ses jeux préférés je crois avec sa
fille c'était de faire des petites
boulettes de mie de pain à table et de
les lancer sur les invités de manière
très discrète et ce qui amusait beaucoup
maman et elle elle trouvé qu'il était
presque un magicien de faire ça parce
que justement ce vieux monsieur
respectable pour sonné le coup de loire
littéraires et autres et ben avait gardé
cet esprit d'enfant
[Musique]
merci julien l'arrière genevois pour
cette visite instructive de la maison de
votre grand-père donc nous sommes devant
les vernel en quoi votre grand père
était-il une sorte d'écologistes du
début du xxème siècle il est un
écologiste parce que transparaît de son
oeuvre l'amour qu'il avait pour la
nature et peut-être plus que d'écologie
à proprement parler parce qu'il se
méfiait beaucoup des grandes phrases et
des grandes théories mais une espèce
d'attention une attention bienveillante
à la nature et l'idée que l'homme et la
nature devait vivre dans une forme
d'harmonie dans laquelle l'homme et
c'est ce qui le rappelle dans nombre de
ses livres dans laquelle l'homme ne peut
pas prendre toute la place qu'il faut
effectivement écouter ce cas nous dire
la nature et c'est vraiment un écrivain
qui s'est fondu dans le val de loire et
il est un emblème merveilleux pour le
val de loire et sa littérature est un
emblème pour le val de loire ça a
toujours été son chez lui et il disait
que c'était son port d'attache et que
c'était là où il se sentait le mieux en
communion avec le monde et disait
d'ailleurs que les vernets l'était le
prolongement de l'enfance qu'il avait
eue et de la chance qu'il avait eue
d'être enfant à châteauneuf sur loire et
que châteauneuf l'avait prédisposé à
toutes les merveilles des vernel et bien
merci julien arrière genevois pour nous
avoir ouvert les portes des vernets la
maison de maurice genevoix ici donc à
saint-denis-de-l'hôtel merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis pendant toute cette
semaine et je vous souhaite
d'excellentes lecture estivale